en ce 12 décembre pour la troisième fois
les calédoniens ont été appelés à se
prononcer sur l'accès à la pleine
souveraineté
après les référendum des 4 novembre 2010
8 et 4 octobre 2020 les calédoniens se
sont prononcés massivement contre
l'accès à la pleine souveraineté à
l'indépendance dans un contexte de forte
abstention
la nouvelle calédonie restera donc
française
en signant l'accord de matignon le 26
juin 1988 jean marie tjibaou et jacques
lafleur ont ouvert à un chemin d'espoir
pour le nouvelle calédonie
quelques semaines plus tard le 6
novembre 1988 la nation tout entière
étaient appelés aux urnes pour entériner
cet accord elle faisait sienne alors la
parole échangée par ses deux grands
hommes de l'histoire calédonienne et
confirmer la pertinence du chemin
dessiné par michel rocard
le 5 mai 1998 dix ans plus tard
les élus calédoniens et l'état signé
l'accord de nouméa et ouvrait la voie
pour la nouvelle calédonie a un avenir
des institutions et un horizon
ce dimanche
fidèle à la sagesse de nos aînés nous
franchissons ensemble une nouvelle étape
l'accord de nouméa arrive à son terme
juridique la promesse du destin commun
dont il était porteur n'a jamais été
aussi tangible et doit continuer à nous
guider
ce soir
reprenant les beaux mots de la coutume
j'accueille la réponse de la nouvelle
calédonie à la question qui lui était
posée avec respect et humilité
respect pour la parole donnée
pour l'accord de nouméa qui nous aura
mené ensemble à ce résultat
respect pour tous les calédoniens tous
ceux qui souhaitaient le maintien dans
la france et ceux qui souhaitaient
l'indépendance
spéte 1 t de reconnaissance pour tous
ceux qui se sont mobilisés depuis de
longs mois pour ce scrutin
les mères et leurs équipes les services
de l'état les forces politiques les
membres de la commission de contrôle les
observateurs internationaux
l'ensemble des calédoniens
humilité car le chemin engagé par nos
prédécesseurs nous dépasse
30 ans trois consultations un processus
unique au monde sous le regard des
nations unies nous ne faisons comprendre
par à une histoire de temps long mais
nous pouvons être fiers de ce
cheminement inédit et pacificateur
humilité car nous aurons besoin de temps
encore si les trois consultations
conduit à dire trois fois non à
l'indépendance
chacune apporté un message différent que
nous devons prendre en compte dans toute
leur épaisseur et nous ne pouvons
ignorer que le corps électoral est resté
profondément divisé malgré le passage
des années
humilité enfin devant l'ampleur de la
tâche qui est la nôtre
une période de transition s'ouvre en
effet qui libérait de l'alternative
binaire entre le oui et le non doit nous
conduire à bâtir un projet commun en
reconnaissant en respectant la dignité
de chacun
le ministre d outre mer est actuellement
en nouvelle calédonie aux côtés des
calédoniens à ma demande
conformément aux engagements pris le 1er
juin 2021 sous l'autorité du premier
ministre il est à votre écoute dès
maintenant pour préparer cette nouvelle
étape
il nous faudra bâtir une réponse aux
questions institutionnelles et
juridiques bien sûr elles seront
nécessaires pour définir une
organisation politique conforme aux
résultats des trois consultations
mais les discussions à venir ne pourront
pas se limiter aux institutions
le lien qui nous unit nez que juridique
c'est un lien charnel un lien de
solidarité un lien humain les derniers
mois l'ont montré dans l'épreuve de la
crise sanitaire la solidarité nationale
s'est révélée plus concrète encore en
nouvelle calédonie comme partout sur le
territoire national
l'action de l'état n'a eu qu'une seule
priorité sauver des vies accompagner les
plus fragiles et je veux avoir en ce
jour une pensée pour toutes celles et
tous ceux qui pleurent un proche
je veux leur dire ma proximité
ma compassion et aussi l'engagement de
la nation à se tenir à vos côtés
dans la crise
la nation a montré son visage
d'aujourd'hui son vrai visage
c'est à ce lien de solidarité de respect
de fraternité
que nous devons être fidèles et ce bien
que nous retiendrons pour l'avenir sur
bien des sujets l'état et les
institutions locales peuvent et doivent
travailler ensemble ce sont d'abord les
sujets d'urgence ceux qui sont devant
nous dans les prochaines semaines la
situation économique
évidemment la situation sanitaire aussi
la relance
l'équilibré des comptes publics le
ministre engagera sur ces sujets un
échange immédiat avec vos élus se sont
aussi la nécessaire réduction des
inégalités qui fragilise l'unité de
l'archipel notre devoir à l'égard de la
jeunesse calédonienne la stratégie
miquel l'autonomie alimentaire et
énergétique le foncier la fiscalité une
croissance plus juste et plus
respectueuse de la nature sont autant de
sujets qui nous permettront de
concrétiser ce nouveau modèle de
croissance
la situation des femmes calédonienne
sera aussi une grande cause des années à
venir elles doivent prendre toute leur
part à ce destin commun
enfin nous aurons à construire une place
pour la nouvelle calédonie dans cette
région de l'inde au pacifique en pleine
recomposition est soumise à de fortes
tensions
ce nouveau projet vous le voyez est ô
combien ambitieux et
ou le construirons ensemble
notamment avec tous ceux qui en nouvelle
calédonie ont moins de 30 ans et n'ont
connu que l'accord de nouméa
ce soir en tant que chef de l'état
garant de nos institutions
je prends donc acte solennellement du
résultat de ces trois scrutins
il confirme la volonté exprimée par la
majorité des calédoniens de rester dans
la république et dans la nation
française
les calédoniennes les calédoniens ont
choisi de rester français ils l'ont
décidé librement
pour la nation entière ce choix est une
fierté et une reconnaissance
ce soir la france est plus belle car la
nouvelle calédonie a décidé d'y rester
à nous tous d'écrire notre histoire avec
ambition et respect une histoire qui se
souvient sans ambiguïté de ce qu'elle
doit au kanak peuples premiers reconnu
par l'accord de nouméa et dont la
présence au sein de la communauté
nationale est une chance inestimable une
histoire qui reconnaît sans faux
semblant l'apport des calédoniens
arriver ensuite sur le caillou pour y
plonger leurs racines et y vivre en
femme en homme libre une histoire qui
regarde devant vers les défis de notre
siècle vers les défis de cet océan
pacifique qui fait partie intégrante de
notre espace national
françaises français
chers compatriotes de nouvelle calédonie
la france est fière d'être votre patrie
elle renouvelle ce soir pour vous son
engagement à vous protéger à vous
accompagner
quelles que soient les circonstances
vive la nouvelle calédonie vive la
république et vive la france